What is up, everyone? Welcome back to your weekly dose
of awesomeness here at Paragliding Atlas Podcast.
And as you can see, this time around, we're coming to you as a
little bit out of schedule. There's a whole reason behind
this, and I'm choosing the word reason instead of an excuse
because no matter how hard we tried, we simply were not able
to publish the episode on Thursday as planned.
To put it simply, we store our recordings in a cloud instead of
on local disks because it's a secure mechanism and it needs a
little bit of editing before we hit the publish button and it
goes out to you guys on all the streaming platforms that you
guys listen to us on. This time around, however, when
I logged in to do that, I was met with nothing but an
unpleasant surprise. The last couple of recordings
that we had scheduled for the coming weeks were just simply
gone, nowhere to be seen. And of course, this took me
aback and I reached out to the support team and I asked them,
hey guys, what's going on? This is this is some critical
data that needs to that needs to be handled well.
And you know, what can we do about this?
And they said that we understand the gravity of the situation,
but the most of the guys who can fix this are out vacationing and
summer holidays. So the earliest we can do this
is sometime next week. This was of course a bit of a
bummer because after faltering on my release schedule for a
little bit in June, I was like, I promised myself that no matter
what happens, I will go out and talk to my audience every week
as planned and bring out all of this knowledgeable content to
you without fail. So I basically saw my own plants
being shattered. To be honest, the feeling wasn't
really good. It was overwhelming and endless
questions were coming to my head.
Do I have to book my guests all over again?
Do I have to recreate the conversations and everything
else that comes around it? And as these emotions were
flooding in like sadness, helplessness, anxiety, and I
could just basically see things spiralling out of control,
damaging my own routine and repetition.
It was just a very hard to digest feeling.
And then I was like, wait a second, this feels a bit
familiar because this is exactly how we feel a lot of times while
flying. And by the way, I'm not talking
about paravating by any means, because nature of course throws
its own things at us which we accept regardless of how ever
prepared we are. But on the other end, when we
are going out and gliding on cross country trips or chasing
the World Cup podiums or you know, want to be in the lead
gaggle, those kind of situations where we have plan that needs to
be put into action. And when the action happens,
some tiny mistakes, some unexpected conditions, some
something unknown comes around and puts it off track and forces
us to rethink our strategy is something very common in flying.
And I realised that we don't really resign, we don't just
accept the outcome. Instead we look for the best
possible Plan B when plan A is flying out of the window.
So I was like, you know what, this is a sign.
And in case those of you who have been following me for quite
a while, I think back in January earlier this year, I said that
I'm going to come out with solo episodes.
But somehow, and of course, I can break blame this on
procrastination for a while that I just never got around to
getting them out to you guys. Because maybe it was a comfort
zone of having a guest in front of me and talking to you guys in
in a tandem manner where it was so much more easier to just have
a conversation with someone rather than just find the
strength and the courage to speak out on a topic by myself.
So I was like, this is basically life telling me that, hey, it's
about time that you make this happen.
So that is how this episode has come to existence and and the
topic of today's episode is managing the unknown when
something surprising happens. And the whole idea of bringing
out this episode was instead of picking up something that I
already planned and drafted was to understand the process that
goes on in our brain when an unexpected situation comes
around. Because when I was feeling all
of these emotions, it was a very weird feeling, something that I
was not comfortable with. So I was like, there must be a
way to manage these situations better.
And I just went up on some reputable websites and started
doing my own research that, you know, what kind of chemicals
release, what is the brain function when such things are
happening? And to be honest, the simplest
answer to these questions are being aware of yourself.
And I know being aware is a very broad word, but in simpler terms
it's being truthful and being being knowledgeable about what
your shortcomings are. And in paragliding terms, I
think being aware can be materialized by airtime.
I know that I keep on talking about airtime answers a lot of
questions, but the point being that airtime allows us to find
the possible shortcomings which we otherwise cannot visualize or
otherwise won't be aware of. Because putting words into
practice is the only way to going out and finding out how
good you are or how complacent you are for that matter, or how
much do you even know about it. So I'd like to point out a quote
here which if you can remember is like a lot of times it is
said that when chaos hits the fan or like when shit hits the
fan, don't think, just do it and trust your training.
I think this is used in combat situations a lot of times by
fighter pilots that when things are going crazy, just trust your
training because you have developed a lot of muscle memory
subconscious. And because over a period of
time by doing those tasks repeatedly, you have developed a
lot of muscle memory. Your subconscious has somehow
figured out a way how to do these actions that you wanted to
without taking a lot of thought behind it.
So I'd like to point out a fact by an Austrian neurologist.
He was a psychologist and a philosopher as well, who goes by
the name of Viktor Frankel. And he said something very
interesting, which was between stimulus and response.
There is a space, and in that space is our power to choose our
response. And in our response lies our
growth and freedom. I'm just going to repeat this
one more time, a bit more slowly, and it is between the
stimuli and the response. So for example, every time there
is something that requires us to respond, there's a space means
there's a pause, there's a lag, there's some thinking that our
brain has to do. And in that pause, lag or
thinking is the power that we have within ourselves to choose
how we respond to that stimuli. And that choosing of our
response is where the actual growth and the freedom lies.
For example, let's say there's a asymmetric One response is to
just go the Safeway, pull a deployment handle and get down
to the ground as safely as possible without doing in a lot
of inputs. The other one is take control of
the wing, do the weight shift, go over the opposite brake or
whatever, depending upon, you know, the wing that you're
flying and the condition that you're in.
So we always have a choice on how to respond and how we
respond is where we can actually make a difference in
understanding the behaviour and making life a whole lot better.
I don't want to sound too philosophical right now, but
another way to put it across is that this whole process is
called metacognition. While metacognition might sound
like a fancy word, but it has a very simple meaning and that is
being aware of your thought patterns.
So let's say every time there is a asymmetric, you have a certain
way of reacting and then being aware of that thought that comes
to your mind and then trying to decode it.
For example, are you panicking every time you hit an asymmetric
or are you like, hey, this is just another day in the park?
Or are you just going out and taking it too lightly?
I'm pretty sure you get get the point.
I'm saying so being aware of the thought pattern.
For example, in my case, for seven months I stayed away from
putting out solo episodes no matter how well prepared I was.
I'm not saying the reasons, but there was a constant pattern
that week after week, month after month, I somehow found
comfort in having a guest talk to me and then put out the
episodes rather than going out and doing the work that I plan
to do. So awareness of the patterns,
that is one of the very important things that you really
have to realise to get better. And then being aware of the
space, the choice of response where we have the option of
growing and finding our freedom is the key to becoming a better
pilot or a human or, you know, just growing generally.
And, and when I was trying to dive deep into this, I was like,
what really happens in the brain?
Like, you know, what are the to do steps that happen so that we
can try and make them better? And I found out that there are
three key brain areas that are located in the front and centre
part of our brain, which are mostly useful for handling our
emotions, decisions and a little bit of social stuff.
I'm not going to dive deep into it, but just to give you a
superficial idea of what we're talking about.
We're talking about prefrontal cortex, which of course, as many
of you know, is like the boss of the brain that plans, decides
and controls our impulses. And then we have anterior
cingulate cortex. Sounds a bit complicated and I
don't think a lot of us have heard this before, but this is a
part of the brain that is basically monitoring the whole
ecosystem that is going on. So it it is the one who spots
the mistake, it is the one who manages the emotional conflicts.
It is the one who helps us stay motivated.
So a lot of feelings are being controlled by the anterior
cingulate cortex. And then there's something very
important here, which is amygdala.
Amygdala is the one which is actually putting our visuals
into action. It is like basically an alarm
system which exists in our brain.
It helps us trigger the fear, it helps us process big emotions.
So every time there is a asymmetric or every time we are
falling out of a thermal which has consequences, or every time
the lead gaggle is leaving us behind, amygdala is the first
one that raises the alarm and says that hey, about time we do
something about it. So how, how the team up is that
amygdala is the first one which freaks out and then the
singulate cortex, the anterior singulate cortex is the one
which is like, OK, what's going on?
You know, let me see, let me understand, let me make some
sense of it. And then once that sense has
been made, the prefrontal cortex is like, all right, guys, calm
down, I'm here now. Now let's try and make some
actual decisions which will make some smart choices and get our
life better. One very important thing here is
that brain has a neurotransmitter which floods
something known as new adrenaline.
New adrenaline, it's a bit of a tongue twister.
It's kind of similar to the regular adrenaline, but the
regular one targets I think heart and blood vessels from
what I read. And this one is flooding the the
impulses in the brain. So they kind of work similarly,
but I think new redolene is more responsible for sharpening the
focus and reaction times and gets us in the zone.
So basically it helps us get in a state of high alert.
And in short, this is a real time crisis management system
kicking in. Now, when this happens, I think
all of us know that there are two ways to go.
The first one, of course, is to calm down while doing some
breathing exercises. A lot of us know about box
breathing. I think that is where you inhale
for like 4 seconds, hold it for four and then exhale for four
and then do it repeatedly. And then you kind of come back
to the normal levels where you can actually start making
rational decisions. The other one, which of course
is more applicable in flying is because there's no way in
dynamic conditions like you know, you're coring a thermal or
you're having an asymmetric, you can't just say that I'm going to
focus on breathing right now because it's action time, it's
go time like you actually have to do something.
This is where it's, and especially it's valid for high
pace environments where there isn't a lot of time to think.
We have something known as neural shortcuts which kick in.
And these neural shortcuts are based on the scenarios that we
have rehearsed over a period of time or practiced again and
again and then gotten better at it.
For example, you have done a full stall multiple times.
So first time glider stalls, you'd be, you'd be scared, you'd
be like, Oh my God, where did the gravity go?
You know, why don't I feel why the feeling of freefall?
But over a period of time when you have gone over that feeling
of freefall repeatedly, you have developed a way that your brain
knows that what kind of glider pressure will exist or how do I
have to handle the brakes. So all of this training that we
have done have built up the confidence in our brain to deal
with it when it happens at a subconscious level so that we
don't really have to do all of those breathing exercises and
get in the zone. Rather, because we have trained
it, we have had cognitive ability developed already in a
safe environment when we knew that the consequences weren't
too hard. We are quick to switch over to
operating something known as sensimotor brain.
In simpler terms, this is also called as flow state, a state of
mind where we can focus on micro resets, which are replacing the
big mindfulness processes. And the science behind this is
that we are entering a tunnel vision of some sort where we are
choosing to direct our focus on things that really matter.
For example, you're going in for the final light, right?
Everybody around you is going on full bar as well.
And somehow you get an asymmetric.
You don't care if the line that you've chosen is correct or not.
Right now, all you care is to get off the bar, get your ring
open again and get back on full bar as quickly as possible.
So the idea here being that your brain, based on the practice
that you've done over a period of time, build up your muscle
memory, build up, your subconscious mind is focusing
for you to just pay attention to fixing the asymmetric and then
coming back to choosing the lines.
So narrowing of attention is something that really happens.
And this is a state of mind when the alertness is super high, the
dopamine is flowing in its full flow because there's motivation
and reward to be chased. And then the cortisol, which is
of course a stress hormone which causes the panic is in a very
controlled level. So in short, this can also be
called as the flow state when actions are feeling automatic,
precise and timeless. There's not a lot of
overthinking, just pure seamless execution based on all the work
that you've put in before. So to sum it up, when something
out of the syllabus comes up and we are confronted to dealing
with the uncertainty in life, we can of course reset by pausing.
But while we're out there racing, we reset by continuing
but with precision. And this is the reason why
mindfulness, journaling, reflective practice, work
therapy could be anything as long as you get to train your
brain to access the reset switch more easily.
Over a period of time, your brain will figure out how to
reach out for better outcomes. And eventually our brain figures
out a way where it learns A mechanism which makes our future
resets a whole lot easier to come.
And this whole behaviour is also called as neuroplasticity.
Now, before we close, I would like to quickly talk about
training tips to boost the neuroplasticity in paragliding.
In simpler words, this can also be called building the gut
feeling or intuition as some people like to call it.
These two words are very closely related.
Intuition is powered by the brain's ability to recognize the
patterns from past experiences, and neuroplasticity makes this
possible by strengthening those patterns over a period of time.
So there are five ways that I've found that allow us to improve
on this and be safe every time we go out and practice the out
of light. The first one, no brainer
practice, simulations, airtime, these three things are actually
the real gold out there, like Sivs, going out there, putting
in the work, you know, flying in different conditions,
thermalling, weak cores, ground handling, anything which helps
you mimic the real world scenario, helps you build the
subconscious mind. And then we have mindfulness and
breath work. Mindfulness and breath work are
two of the most important tools that can be applied in vast
aspect of life, not just in flying, because they in general
help us reduce stress and improve the focus.
And eventually when we are less stressed and we are more
focused, our brain absorbs and stores the experiences better.
Try waking up first thing in the morning instead of picking up
your phone and scrolling on social media.
Try reading a book or try just thinking about some thoughts.
This has happened to me where I somehow feel that my emotions
flow or my feelings flow a lot better first thing in the
morning. Because first thing in the
morning we are not at all stressed.
We can totally focus because our brain is completely blank.
So anyways, moving on visualization.
Now visualization is a superpower, I think a lot less
spoken about. And we definitely have an
episode on visualization coming out which will help you
understand that how training to visualize correctly will help
you go far. But mentally rehearsing takeoff,
mentally rehearsing circling in weak thermals or any other
emergency responses because science has time and again shows
that visualization activates the same circuits in our brain as
the real practice. And then lastly, there are two
things which will help you go far.
The first one being cross training.
A lot of times I've seen physical fitness is not
emphasized upon enough in our sport just like it is in
conventional sports. But believe it or not, the
amount of core usage that we have in panel lighting is
undermined as compared to other conventional sports activities
like balance training, yoga, anything which improves your
strength will improve the body control and the mind body
connection. So the coordination and
everything else becomes a whole lot better.
And then finally journalling. I'm pretty sure a lot of pilots
do this already or I hope they do and this is being told as
soon as you graduate from the school.
But this is I think where we have some complacency to blame
about and me including because once we are done with the school
we just forget about making journaling a part of our flight.
Logging it was like uploading the flight is more than enough
and we just make a mental map of our flight.
But what we don't understand is that every time we write down
something. I think there was a study where
writing with pen had a direct connection to the mind.
I'm not really sure if tapping on a screen or using a keyboard
has the same effect or not, but all I'm saying is that
reflecting on each flight will help us consolidate the learning
and identify patterns in a whole lot better manner.
And once you're able to identify your patterns, you're able to
learn from your mistakes, which eventually I think is the key to
becoming a better way of yourself.
So that's all I have for you guys in this episode.
Do let me know how you find this one.
Drop in a comment or an e-mail wherever you listen to this and
I'll be sure to bring out more awesomeness to you, hopefully as
planned next Thursday as we do usually.
Until then, thank you for tuning in and I hope you liked it.